24 лютого 2022 року це буде видатна дата
для України тому що в цей момент Україна
почала знищувати російську федерацію в
тому вигляді політичному в якому вона
існує
мобілізація країни і під час війни це
готовність країни захищатись ця війна -
це не про донат просто і таким чином Ти
вважаєш що ти приймаєш участь у війні
і не закінчимо цю війну десь посередині
війна посередині буде означати що
Україна вмерла не за три дні за три роки
можливість звільнити Крим абсолютно
і якомога швидше набагато навіть швидше
ніж Донецьк і Луганськ
про річницю повномасштабного вторгнення
західну зброю і мобілізацію в Україні Ми
говоритимемо з радником голови офісу
президента Михайлом подаляком пане
згадаємо 24 лютого 22-го року ми
говоримо з вами напередодні цієї дати
напередодні річниці повномасштабного
вторгнення яким для вас був цей день Як
для вас почалася повномасштабна війна
Я думаю що ми його на те що згадувати ми
його будемо завжди пам'ятати 24 лютого
2022 року це буде видатна дата для
України тому що в цей момент Україна
почала знищувати російську федерацію в
тому вигляді політичному в якому вона
існує просто Росія - це ще не до кінця
розуміє і зрозуміє це на спецстрибулі
обов'язково але між тим починалось це
зрозуміло в 4:30 ранку Як я пригадую
були обстріли території України обстріли
і я прокинувся Саме від цих обстрілів і
практично відразу поїхав на роботу все
тут на роботі вже було засідання Ради
оборони і нацбезпеки на якому приймали
ключові рішення готувались в принципі ті
закони які були потрібні для ведення
воєнного стану і безумовно піднявся до
президента побачив абсолютно рішучу
людину яка точно розуміла що
відбувається Що будемо робити що ми
нікуди не поїдемо і що в принципі в нас
є всі шанси
перебудувати систему управління система
керування країною на військові рейки
достатньо Швидко я зразу скажу що не
ідеально все було безумовно але між тим
десь до восьмої ранку Я вже зрозумів що
в нас є кому захищати цю країну Із точки
зору управління І з точки зору
безпосередньої дії на полі бою мається
на увазі тоді поебоя було скрізь по всій
країні
тож манку 24 лютого Це для вас особисто
було несподіванкою
Це складне питання для мене було
несподіванкою скоріше обсяг саме
втручання
колонами танків які заходили по всій
країні і було трошки несподіванкою що
людина на прізвище Путін буде наносити
удари по всій Україні мені видавались що
ми точно будемо мати певні бойові дії
ідентифікацію бойових дій але на окремих
напрямках Я просто чому повертаюсь до 24
лютого тому що досі на адресу офісу
президента зокрема лунає багато критики
чому не попереджали людей про Реальну
небезпеку адже можна було би уникнути
Бучі можна було уникнути Ось цього
геноциду який ми бачили тут на Київщині
наприклад давайте по-перше попереджати
про що ми мали півтора роки до війни
навколо наших кордонів 150 тисяч на
угрупування російських військ було там з
16 чи може навіть більше попереджень що
ось завтра почнеться війна останнє ви
пам'ятаєте 16 лютого мало бути
повноцінне вторгнення друге багато країн
європейських казали що точно не буде
ніякого вторгнення тому що це неможливо
в принципі і казали якщо ви будете оце
все говорити то ми будемо якось дивно на
вас дивитися не будемо ну оцінювати вас
як людей які адекватно сприймають
реальність це багато партнерів говорили
третя складова щодо щодо обсягу
вторгнення були знову ж таки оцінки про
те що так може бути вторгнення але його
обсяг ніхто не розумів ну тобто що це
буде що яким чином це буде відбуватися
четверта складова така Ніхто не знав що
буде такого типу війна геноцидного типу
конкретно геноцидного типу як ми
побачили потім в Бучі ми це з вами
зрозуміли коли це вже було березень
кінець березня початок квітня ми тільки
тоді зрозуміли який тип війни до цього
ми думали що все ж таки Росія - це якась
країна яка більш-менш дотримується
цивілізаційних норм поведінки Я вже не
кажу про міжнародне право а просто
цивілізаційний і вона наносить удари по
військовим тому що воює з нами але вона
не вбиває цивільних масово не очікується
з них не створює для них неможливі умови
існування це і дивіться Якби ми не
встояли то сьогодні про це навіть ніхто
б не говорив тому що всі пробили вигляд
чи навіть не знали того що Росія робила
в Бучі чи там скажімо в Куп'янську чи в
Херсоні це по факту завжди легко
говорити нарешті А щоб ну Навіть якби
було попередження що буде масштабне
вторгнення такого типу ми мали про
евакуатувати 40 мільйонів Ну це ж
нонсенс тобто не було помилкою
заспокоювати людей говорити що в травні
будуть шашлики що все буде добре Це не
було помилкової стратегією комунікації
помилковою є існування Російської
Федерації яку не розумів Інший світ який
загравав з Росією даває
надаючи їм відчуття безкарності
і це не помилка конкретно України тільки
це помилка демократичної освіти якщо вже
треба про це говорити тому що якби якби
наші партнери разом з нами вважали що
дійсно буде масштабна війна то тоді
зброя мала бути в Україні не сьогодні
в лютому 2023 а в лютому 2021 чи в
лютому 2020-го і чітко сказати ви знаєте
ми розуміємо що вони з 16 напрямків
зайдуть на територію України
величезною кількістю танків бронетехніки
розвардії щоб нас різати ну це трошки
фантастично б звучало в січні 2022 мені
видається так питання не в тому питання
в іншому так само як і в Другій Світовій
Чи зможете ви швидко мобілізуватися Чи
зможете ви швидко прийняти рішення Чи
зможете ви побудувати правильні системи
керування перебудувати країну на
військові рейки домовитись суспільством
про квартиру що ми разом Йдемо до кінця
вмовити партнерів не боятись Росії і
сказати партнерам одну ключову фразу
Дивіться ви просто маєте на нас дивитись
бо ми не будемо здаватись не будемо
ставати на коліна ми будемо йти до кінця
самі чи з вами зі зброєю чи з руками але
будемо йти до кінця Оце треба було
зробити ми це зробили
Я маю на увазі ми це Україна
про підсумок останніх 12 місяців такі
невеликі якщо його можна зробити щоб ви
називали основним здобутком України за
цей час
вміння
брати на себе лідерські функції
Україна
дуже швидко стала суб'єктом глобального
рівня
Україна дуже швидко замкнула на себе
формування порядку денного глобального
Україна дуже швидко приймає рішення
Україна точно демонструє світ що
книжкові герої є в реальності
ну Європа ж дуже любить читати книги про
те як треба боронити свою свободу любить
конечно фільми дивитись про те що є люди
які можуть
одноосібно вставати навпроти орди яка
хоче забрати в тебе сім'ю у дітей і так
далі а Україна все це показує в
реальному часі що герої живуть поряд з
тобою ми повертаємо світу це відчуття що
цінності це не просто якісь там слова
які ти написав в Конституції чи в яких з
деклараціях і так далі ми показуємо що
таким треба бути і тоді і тоді ти
виграєш якщо ми вже згадали про помилки
і про те що їх треба аналізувати тож що
є найбільшою помилкою За ці останні 12
місяців для України
найбільшою помилкою є
іноді ми дозволяємо собі достатньо м'яко
розмовляти між собою Я маю на увазі
держава як Конституція і суспільства А
на мій погляд треба все ж таки жорстко
розмовляти
і говорити відверто про те що це не
просто якась абстрактна війна де воюють
збройні сили України якими ми пишаємось
ми ж любимо говорити це війна країни
проти іншої країни це війна мобілізації
мобілізація маю на увазі ресурс України
психологічного ресурсу в тому числі
проти мобілізації іншої країни і ця
війна це не про донат просто і таким
чином Ти вважаєш що ти приймаєш участь у
війні це війна про те що ти точно маєш
розуміти що доведеться платити величезну
ціну всім не тільки збройним силам от ми
дуже м'яко це говорили і я вважаю що це
ключова помилка Ми з першого дня хотіли
все ж таки дати певний психологічний
захист в країні сказати що все ми
контролюємо не переживайте Так ми
контролюємо як інституція контролюємо
але але треба переживати тому що
Дивіться це питання виживання Це питання
чи хочемо ми організувати в рамках
української концепції світу чи буде
Україна продовжувати мобілізацію
це питання яке вирішується операційному
рівні збройними силами генеральним
штабом це питання яке вирішується на
рівні комунікації то як підрозділ
збройних сил збройні сили які розуміють
що потрібно на тому чи іншому напрямку з
урахуванням кількості знову ж таки
російських мобілізованих і Міноборони Ну
і центри територіальні центри
комплектування які входять всю цю
інфраструктуру мобілізація є
необов'язковою частиною під час війни
але я хочу щоб ми правильно термін цей
окреслили мобілізація це ж не конкретно
про те що треба брати 100 тисяч 100
тисяч 100 тисяч відправляти на передній
край ні мобілізація країни під час війни
це готовність країни захищатись це
тренування тренування іще раз тренування
це треба щоб людина була свідома того
щоб вона не ховалася від розуміння що
треба навчитись користуватись зброєю що
треба навчитись елементарних речей
що треба вміти вбивати бо це
психологічно складно розумієте що
складно вбити якщо ти бачиш обличчя
ворого артилерію легко вбити 20
кілометрів а вистрілити в обличчя ворогу
дуже складно психологічно і треба цьому
навчатись оце треба людям пояснювати і
ми недостатньо жорстко це робили і я
вважаю що це помилка тому що ми вважали
Ну я особисто що суспільство настільки В
нас дорослих що може само між собою
обговорювати всі ці складні речі
говорити Так нам страшно але ми будемо
робити все для того щоб бути готовими
вбивати ворога в повному обсязі хтось на
передньому краї хтось в тилу і так далі
і я ще раз кажу це не питання
патріотизму до НАТО це питання
усвідомлення того що Росія має програти
а Росія має програти не дипломатично
На жаль нам би хотіли щоб можна було
прийти сказати відведіть свої війська і
вони втекли Ні Росія
вже розуміє що війна йде по їх плану але
цей План був Як я розумію руйнування
самої Російської Федерації але між тим
Росія розуміє тільки кулак в обличчя
і якомога більшим порушенням
нижньої і верхньої челюсті ми не
закінчимо цю війну десь посередині немає
в нас такого шансу ми маємо пояснити
людям що війна посередині буде означати
що Україна вмерла не за три дні за три
роки чи правильно Я розумію що питання
зняття обмеження на виїзд чоловіків за
кордон зараз немає підніматися та
безумовно Я ще кажу про це що давайте
все ж таки більш жорсткого між собою
говорити Не треба спекуляцій що значить
обмежена прав чи крім прав людей В
Україні є обов'язок якийсь чи ні Чи ми
тільки про права що держава повинна дати
що держава повинна забезпечити чимось
дати можливість виїхати дати можливість
жити як людина хоче так у мирний час все
дамо але під час війни так не ставиться
питання питання ставиться інакше хочеш
перетнути кордон Тобто ти хочеш сказати
що Україна має перестати існувати тому
що ти ж перетнув кордон
тому що коли ми говоримо відкрити
кордони для чоловіків Це означає що ми
говоримо Хто хоче втікти від прийняття
для себе конкретно чоловічого рішення
хто я вони хочуть втікти і це є
відповідь на рішення Хто ви і це важливо
німецькі аналітики говорять що Росія
здатна мобілізувати ще мільйон людей до
речі керівник офісу президента Андрій
Ярмак теж говорив що от сама кількість
людей у Росії це вже для України
проблема Як цю проблему вирішувати зброю
Здрастуй оружие
перефразованих Хемінгуей
зброя зброя і зброя багато зброї багато
зброї летального дальнобійного плану
ракети снаряди
безпілотники авіація штурмова перш за
все
бронетехніка Все давайте правильно
говорити про мобілізаційний компонент
безумовно коли німецькі аналітики
говорять про те що в Росії щось є вони
нам що хочуть сказати що ми не розуміємо
що є в Росії Ми не розуміємо що 140
мільйонів це 140 мільйонів що що його є
такі суб'єкт в якості міністра оборони
дивний безумовно але супер що він в них
міністр оборони
він говорить що мобілізаційний ресурс
Росії 30 мільйонів ми це не розуміємо
Тобто нам треба пояснити якісь прописні
істини ну тобто нам треба якісь банальні
речі сказати Тоді в мене питання до цих
аналітики А ви можете своєму уряду
сказати що Україна на коліна становитись
не буде Україна продовжить воювати тому
що це питання її існування подальшого
і тоді треба зброю щоб оцей мільйон
знищити потрібно наприклад 500 тисяч
снарядів калібру 155 але себе випускати
не будуть тобто Україна ж також розуміє
що український людський ресурс він не
настільки не обмежений що Україна не
відправляє людей як м'ясо на війну
правда це ж високотехнологічна війна Я ж
про це і кажу не питання в кількості
мобілізованих для нас якщо ми хочемо
виграти цю війну це питання в кількості
високоточної зброї яка в нас є а це
знову ж таки конкретні артилерійські
системи це конкретні системи млрс
конкретні дальнобійні ракети включно з
легендарним вже для нас атакамсом тому
що вони дозволять оцей мільйон знищити
там де вони ще тільки починають на себе
вдягати штани
це очевидні речі я кажу мільйон страшний
коли він підходить на 10 метрів обличчя
в обличчя тоді ти точно навіть якщо ти
дуже круто використовуєш стрілецьку
зброю пістолет автомат
той фізично не зможеш знищити якщо їх
буде 20-30 людей тому що там є
географічні можливості
об'єкти з яких в тебе будуть стріляти і
ти не виграєш війну стрілковою зброєю
просто тоді виникає
логічне питання Коли ось наприклад Джо
Байден так був у Києві з дуже важливим
дуже символічним візитом Він сказав про
700 танків про тисячі броньованих машин
про новий пакет допомоги від Сполучених
Штатів але він не сказав про ті ж самі
далекобійні ракету Чи провинищувачі вони
будуть і ракети і винищувачі ви задаєте
фундаментальні питання цієї війни коли
я відповідаю ми працюємо постійно над
цим постійно говоримо одні й ті ж самі
речі тобто от є принципова нічого вже і
президент і інші переговорники з нашою
сторони тисячу разів повторили
принципи цієї війни на різних
майданчиках і повторимо ще 10 тисяч
разів питання Коли знімемо питання Коли
вже набагато швидше вирішується просто є
один нюанс Ми живемо в одному часовому
вимірі для нас хвилина
вартує життя когось Вони живуть в
традиційному бюрократичному вимірі коли
можна неспешно
випити
філіжанку кави проблема тільки в
бюрократії проблеми в рішучості ми ж з
вами говорили про те що на сьогоднішній
день в світі існує Одна країна з
величезною рішучістю На жаль Якби було
таких країн хоча б 10 війна вже давно
закінчилась але я повертаюсь ще раніше
на Три кроки назад
військово-промисловий комплекс заходу і
наш не були готові до такої
інтенсивності війни і тому Росія просто
накопичила в неї теж нема високоточної
зброї але є величезна кількість
радянської апгрейженої в тому числі
зброї і вони її втрачають вони вже
будуть демілітаризованою державою Після
цієї війни в них нічого не буде
принципово згода від партнерів щодо
ракети і винищувачів вона є а принципова
згода є щодо ракет щодо винищувачів
Зараз саме активна фаза переговорів і ми
отримуємо принципову згоду не тільки
винищувачем ви говорите про винищувачі
тому що це дійсно інструмент для
закриття неба для перехоплення балістики
яку Росія сьогодні використовує в
більшому обсязі і для перехоплення
гіперзвуку ну тобто ті вже кинджалів От
для цього потрібні f16
з компонентом перехоплювання а для того
щоб ефективно вбивати нищити російські
ресурси на сході і півдні України
потрібні штуки це інше завдання Але я
думаю що принципова згода буде якомога
швидше буде тому що наші партнери все ж
таки повільно але розуміють що якщо ми
сказали що ця війна закінчиться поразкою
Росії то певно треба це цього добитись
інакше Якщо ця війна закінчиться якимось
компромісом за рахунок України це буде
означати що демократія слабка система і
глобальний світ має звернути більше
прискіпливої уваги на авторитарній
системі які дозволяють тобі приходити
будь-куда вбивати нищити і нанести за це
відповідальність як ви оцінюєте
вірогідність наступу нового наступу
Росії з півночі з північного напрямку ми
не бачимо сьогодні розвідка достатньо
активно моніторить все що відбувається в
Білорусії і з точки зору військового І з
точки зору політичної економічної точки
зору ми не бачимо там сьогодні
комплектування ударного формування
давайте об'єктивно це ж не просто так
буде наступ чи не буде я розумію що це
на вулиці можна говорити а для нас
важливі цифри параметри конкретика
конкретика така Для того щоб ефективно
піти з північного наступу ну з
білоруської території там наприклад на
Чернігів Київ чи на будь-яку іншу місто
України там рівна Луцьк і так далі
потрібно певна кількість людей і техніки
певна кількість людей це починається 30
Це мінімум тисяч Але для того щоб
ефективно просуватись по такій відстані
треба 70-80 тисяч угрупування тому що
сьогодні ще інша ситуація сьогодні ні 24
лютого
2022 року для цього щоб така отаке
угрупування було Вона має отримати
півтори тисячі бронетехніки різних видів
перш за все тяжкої воно має отримати
500-600 гармат різних калібрів 122 152
воно має отримати фронтову фронтові зрк
ну чи протиракетні системи воно має
отримувати
величезну логістичне забезпечення А це
транспорт транспорту транспорту це все
відсутнє сьогодні в Білорусі в Білорусі
сьогодні присутні полігони які
використовували Росія для тренування
своїх військовослужбовців і величезний
інформаційний компонент тому що гібридну
війну ніхто не відміняв і постійні
постійні провокації інформаційні які
мають трошки ввести нас в паніку
особливо ввести в паніку суспільство ще
кілька питань з нашої внутрішньої
політики чому досі на керівних посадах в
комітетах Верховної Ради є представники
забороненої партії опозиційної платформа
за життя Чому так довго Вони залишаються
гарне питання Я думаю що вам буде бажано
його задати очільникам парламенту як
такого тому що я вважаю Ви праві але є
процедурні питання для того щоб
людину виключити позбавити її тих чи
інших повноважень зняти з голови того чи
іншого ключового комітету треба пройти
певні процедурні
процес Я думаю що вони будуть зроблені в
парламенті маємо ввести жорстку
люстрацію цих людей і так далі я
абсолютно з вами погоджуюсь але але все
ж таки є два нюанси перше
ми маємо робити все законно Тому що наші
партнери на такі речі звертають увагу і
вони оці люди яких ми по звільняємо якщо
ми порушимо хоча б якусь процедурну
норму вони обов'язково підуть в
Європейський суд по правам людини щоб
довести що їх права там якісь були
порушені і друга складова ми маємо
зважати на те що перебудова ідеологічна
країна яка певний час жила в такому
двозначному вимірі що з одного боку ми
про європейський а з іншого у нас велика
частина країни годується проросійською
пропагандою ідеологію ми маємо зрозуміти
що це питання
трансформації певного часу
і ми пройдемо через це в нас не буде
проросійськості взагалі я навіть не
уявляю собі що якась істота подібна
медведчуково Може тут отримати знову ж
таки якийсь мандат на якомусь навіть
місцевому рівні яке майбутнє української
православної церкви Та що вже не називає
себе МП
Вона може себе називати як завгодно але
юридично мені видається
ми як держава не втручаємося безумовно
справи конфесії таке інше але мені
видається дивним що в країні з таким
серцем як Україна існує якихось дві
помісні православні церкви в нас є одна
православна церква наша ну для мене Це
очевидно Одна країна одна церква не може
бути церква яка має таке чи таке чи інше
відношення до іншої церкви існуючої в
країні ворог в країні яка на нас напала
це перше друга складова
Служба безпеки України вкрай ефективно
проводить роботу з цією церквою з точки
зору виявлення там певних нюансів і
фінансових і ідеологічних і кадрових і
ми бачимо що багато
багато представників цієї церкви в рясах
втікають у Москву це питання безумовно
треба вирішувати знову ж таки поступово
і воно буде вирішуватись поступово але
мені видається що репутаційно тут все
вже Зрозуміло у нас є єдина помісна
церква і так має бути і після цієї війни
так і буде і просто ще є певні залишки
які із елементи
впливу Росії на нас які культивувались
там 10-річчями це ж було розгалужена
мережа як у Росія використовувала і вони
продовжують спротив Якісь вони хочуть
отримати можливість все ж таки
затриматись на нашій території Але я
думаю що це все вже питання часу коли це
все закінчиться так само як інформаційні
впливи російські політичні впливи ви
собі уявляєте проросійсько-політичну
партію
Я до речі знаєте це дуже дивно я взагалі
я коли ми кажемо що наприклад у Криму в
14-му році Практично всі хотіли
проголосувати за Росію ви знаєте що
наприклад аксіонов цей собі як дивний Да
що він на виборах він акцентував увагу
на тому що він абсолютно проросійський
там була якась Вперед Росія чи як його
там партія називалась він набирав там по
півтора відсотки всього-на-всього тобто
такої конкретної живої підтримки
проросійськості навіть в Криму ніколи не
було ми не можемо жити в шизофренії В
нас може бути тільки українське
українське політичний простір українські
інформаційний простір де можуть бути
партнери які приходять з об'єктивної
інформації Я маю на увазі іноземні
компанії і таке інше в нас буде
український культурний простір
знову ж таки можуть прийти англомовні
пропозиції
німецькомовні пропозиції Франко фоні
пропозиції і так далі в нас буде
український музичний простір Український
релігійний простір це є об'єктивний
розвиток історичний
і Росії тут не буде ви згадали вже про
корин тому на останок давайте якраз про
Крим трошки і поговоримо західні
експерти західні військові генерали
говорять навіть про те що до кінця літа
Україна може звільнити Крим до кінця
літа цього року Як ви оцінюєте такий
сценарій чи поділяєте таку думку і
будь-який ваш сценарій того як Україна
звільнятиме Крим безумовно можна
говорити про різні прогнози але війна -
це
просто скрупульозна математика чітко є
такі-то такі-то обсяги зброї такі-то
такі-то задачі будуть вирішені до такого
часу немає задачі будуть витягуватись
Все і так само з тієї сторони безумовно
Ми йдемо реалізуємо Росію дуже сильно і
візит байдена до речі деморалізував ви
бачили виступ на наступний день суб'єкта
Путіна ви бачили як він виглядає людина
з брежнєвской интонацією в Голосі знову
ж таки Розказує що на нього напали
тобто він напав раніше ну і Він вбиває
людей тому що могли вбити його ну дивні
слова
прогниваючі капіталізм захід з яким
треба воювати тому що ми не дозволимо
наших дітей якось там кудись перевернути
Ці діти правда втікають жити в Європу
тому що там є можливості в Росії
можливості Тільки
сидіти і пити ну Зрозуміло Але між тим
щодо Криму
логіка війни така що
можливість звільнити Крим абсолютно
і якомога швидше набагато навіть швидше
ніж Донецьк і Луганськ хоча мені
видається що ми маємо максимально
жорстко звільнити Донецький Луганськ Це
було б символічно тому що оця істота яка
постійно виступає да говорить про
донбасский народ треба звільнити цю
територію просто звільнити щоб ця істота
перестала ображати слово Донбас
щоб в неї був такий комплексний
повноцінності да от табличка Донбас А ми
зробимо так будемо Росія постійно
говорити Донбас хочу задати питання
Росії Ну щоб в них було таке знаєте
мандражували постійно це дуже важливо
але щодо Криму оперативно-тактично це
буде зроблено достатньо швидко при
виконанні певних умов знову ж таки
це
як буду заплановані Контр операції наші
це обсяги зброї і це можливість
досягнути
напів острові Крим скрізь ракетами А
такам пан Михайло Дякую вам за цю
розмову